hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
pct and aid to antibiotic decision
making
i am michelle ashton of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want and any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
please click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now present today's speaker
dr trevor van schuneveld
associate professor in the division of
infectious disease
department of internal medicine at the
university of nebraska medical center
in omaha nebraska for a complete
biography on our speaker
please visit the bogzy tab at the top of
your screen
dr van you may now begin your
presentation welcome
thank you thank you for having me today
i'm going to talk about procalcitonin
and its utility in helping us make
antibiotic decisions
these are my objectives at first we're
going to talk a little bit about
the biochemistry and the physiology of
procalcitonin the kinetics how it works
we're then going to look at some of the
literature on how
how it can be useful in loris retract
infection and sepsis
we're going to talk a little bit about
how it can be utilized with the current
viral
chronovirus pandemic based on the
currently available literature and then
we'll talk a very at the very end some
best practices on how to
implement if you haven't and how to
utilize more effectively and efficiently
efficiently
now i want to start off with a poll
question this is a case that i saw
a 30 year old male has diabetes type 2
presented to the edie with fever cough
chills nausea vomiting and body aches
for three days
said it felt like a truck had run over
him now this was a couple years ago
not right now we don't think he had
coveted maybe right now his white count
was normal
lactic acid was normal his chest x-ray
showed by basilar pulmonary opacities
the radiologist said suspect developing
consolidation
this rapid flu is positive for influenza
b and so we have a poll question
that we'd like you to ask would you
start antibiotics
in this patient and so that poll
question should start
should pop up for you to answer
all right so we have a diabetic yes
fever's cough
feels terrible he's positive for flu
certainly sounds like flu
and um the hole basically shows i'll
send you
uh the results 77 said no they wouldn't
start antibiotics so let's go on to the
next slide
what if i told you is procalcitonin was
.75
so we're just going to ask the exact
same question
would you start antibiotics same patient
same exact presentation we now have a
procalcitonin of 0.75
so 81 percent now are saying yes that
they would start
and so i think it's interesting to see
that i always like to start out with
that to just see how people would
interpret
and what they think of procalcitonin
this is i think a great example of pro
where procalcitonin can have some
utility uh because generally it'd say
fluvia you know they feel crummy that's
kind of what we expect what i'll tell
you is
this gentleman overnight grew group b
strep no group a strep
in his bloodstream but he had gotten
started in antibiotics and
typical cap antibiotics and actually did
pretty well and was home in about two or
three days
but he definitely had a bacterial
infection so um
let's talk about procalcitonin so we all
can probably acknowledge that antibiotic
use is
not optimal suboptimal a lot of use in
the hospital that's either unnecessary
and appropriate
it's a big drive of resistance it causes
toxicities renal dysfunction c diff you
name it
we use a lot of antibiotics we probably
don't need to and why do we do that well
it's actually because the diagnosis of
bacterial infection is kind of hard
and if you look at sepsis studies
diagnosis of sepsis i mean the gold
standard of sepsis
is really we gave some antibiotics
because we thought they had an infection
they got better
pretty rare we find etiology of sepsis
somewhere around 30 to 60
of the time the cultures are often
negative or they just grow contaminants
and they get better and we say well they
must have had an infection
similar with pneumonia the clinical
diagnosis pneumonia is difficult
the etiology and the very aggressive
diagnostic studies is only determined
up to maybe half the time usually much
lower blood cultures have a really
low yield so low that the recent cap
guidelines suggested that they be
abandoned
except in severe cap similarly sputum
culture gram stain a lot of people can't
produce it
and then once you start antibiotics
rapidly makes it
uh we can't detect a lot of the
pathogens so it actually is really hard
to diagnose bacterial infections
and so we use biomarkers right and what
are biomarkers biomarkers are measurable
characteristics that reflect the
severity or presence of some disease
state currently an infection we use
things like fever white blood cell
counts crp
these are the biomarkers we use now the
ideal biomarker of infection
and it doesn't exist yet that we know of
is sensitive doesn't miss anybody with a
bacterial infection
and it's specific it's not positive
people who don't have a bacterial
infection it'd be nice in this ideal
biomarker if the higher it was
the more likely it was that someone's
infected and so a 0.2
would mean something less different than
a 2 and a 20 would mean something
different than that
it'd be nice if when we treated somebody
that biomarker went down and reflected
sort of the progression of the infection
and it'd be really good if it wasn't
confounded by immunosuppression other
conditions which are a lot of the
problems we have with our current
biomarkers
and then any biomarker to be useful has
got to be fast so we can use it to make
decisions
and everything needs to be cheap these
days right so
the ideal buyer marker does not exist
what i will tell you is
right now procalcitonin is the best and
this is just my opinion the best
biomarker
for bacterial infection that we have is
it perfect no
but it's the best we got pro-calcitonin
under normal physiologic condition so
procalcitonin is a product of the calc
gene the calcine is actually
usually used to produce calcitonin it
produces this
precursor peptide which is then
processed in the golgi apparatus and
secreted under this highly endocrine
regulated system of gastrin and calcium
and a bunch of stuff that
i don't remember anymore from medical
school and residency
and it's produced by a few small cells
in the thyroid gland
and normal physiologic conditions are
just picogram levels of procalcitonin
now what happens is under bacterial
infection state where there's
lipopolysaccharides and the inflammatory
cytokines released by bacterial
infection
there's what people may term a hormokine
production of procalcitonin that means
sort of
all over production where that same gene
is transcribed
but doesn't have the post-translation
modification translational modification
the golgi apparatus
and is just secreted as calcitonin and
it's secreted rapidly
and it's secreted from many tissues
interestingly that production is
generally inhibited by the cytokines
produced by viral infection like
interferon gamma
what tissues produce procalcitonin well
under normal physiologic states which is
healthy thyroid and a few of those
neuroendocrine cells in the lung but
under
sepsis or other inflammatory states it's
a whole host of tissues and so
you can't really remove the tissue or
the cell line that produces
pro-calcitonin which is one of its
advantages it's also more widespread
than cytokines
cytokines do stimulate its release
it is driven by cytokine release these
are this is data generated through
lipopolysaccharide experiments when they
inject lipopolysaccharide
and measure major cytokines and other
biomarkers
what you can see here is the first thing
to rise are the inflammatory cytokines
il-6 il-10 tnf-alpha
pro-calcium follows soon after that the
cytokines have not quite
yet been useful as biomarkers of
infection
it may be in the future we'll have a
panel of cytokines and procalcitonin or
other biomarkers that will help us even
more
than any individual marker but right now
the cytokinesis aren't very practical in
sorting this out
you can see pro-calcium levels rise
within six to twelve hours
and typically hit their peak by about 12
hours after
the inflammatory insult once that
inflammatory insult is removed the
infection's removed the
levels begin to decline and they decline
in a relatively predictable way
of about 50 every 24 hours that's a
rough estimate
you can see crp does the same thing it's
just more delayed in its response
something to know about pro calcium
because it's produced by systemic
cytokine release it's not really
produced when you have localized
infections like localized abscess or
cystitis or osteomyelitis while those
can produce fever
they just don't generally produce the
level of systemic cytokines
needed to drive procalcitonin so that's
something to keep in mind that it's not
use it's not really useful for those
localized infections
the dynamics of procalcitonin are very
important and this is something that i
think it's very important for people to
understand
is that while an individual value is
useful
a couple of values can be even even more
use and we'll talk later a little bit
about how that is
the nice thing about procalcitonin is
its dynamic reflects what's going on
with the patient
these are patients neutropenic patients
actually
who had bacteremia or severe sepsis and
what you can see is those who responded
to treatment they were getting better
the procalcitonins came down nicely
those were they weren't responding to
therapy the patient wasn't getting
better
broadcast didn't go down and actually
appeared to be going up
and that dynamic of procalcitonin
decline or non-decline or rise
is actually predictive of uh outcome
been a number of studies that have
looked at this this is one that looked
at ventilated social pneumonia
and they compared people who survived
and those who didn't those survived
their pro calciums were elevated
but then dropped the uh sort of pro
calcium
initial pro calcium wasn't really
predictive but it was really that
dynamic those who didn't survive have
actually rising procalcitonins at day
four and this is actually
a prognostic marker for sepsis as well
those non-declining procalcitonins
are not a good sign
and so just to briefly summarize what i
could have talked about an hour
on is that pro calcium is produced
ubiquitously through cyto after cytokine
production
um produced by bacterial infection it's
the most specific and we'll talk a
little bit about this a little bit
biomarker for bacterial infection
currently available
the re levels rise rapidly they decline
predictably
non-declining pro-calisthenians
certainly can indicate a lack of
infection control and
we won't talk much about this but that
is sort of the way i think about it
i'm treating an infection the pro
calcium is not going down
it makes me re-evaluate things do i need
to switch therapy
am i missing something the patient's
getting better i generally just kind of
sit tight and monitor but if the
patient's not getting better and the
biomarkers aren't getting better
i start to get kind of nervous that's
i'm i'm missing something
uh and it's not impaired by neutropenia
or other immunosuppressive states
generally
now there are some things that can
confound your procalcitonin and it's
really important you understand these
if you're going to utilize procalcitonin
any sort of massive physiologic stress
because it results in cytokine release
is going to cause
procalcitonin relief and so it turns out
being born is a major physiologic stress
now procalcine is not approved for use
in neonates
although there are centers that do use
it generally when they use it
anything before 72 hours after birth
they don't usually use because being
born is
stressful apparently and after that
usually it's recommended to interpret
as usual any sort of major physiologic
stress
trauma major surgery cardiogenic shock
cpr
burns any of that stuff is going to
cause a release of inflammatory
cytokines
and a rise in your procalcitonin value
what will happen though is if you
resolve that it should trend down back
to normal and i could show you
numerous studies but don't have time to
do it looking at post-cardiac surgery
post-transplant surgery
where after surgery the levels go up and
then decline nicely
back down to normal at about 50 per day
any sort of prolonged severe
non-resolving
physiologic problem or organ perfusion
abnormality
like cardiogenic shock that's not
getting resolved or
ischemic bowel that's not being fixed
can cause procalcitonin rise and that's
because we have again
ongoing release of inflammatory
mediators perhaps leak of
lipopolysaccharide
and it just doesn't go down until you
really fix the problem that doesn't
necessarily mean the infection is out of
control
and so you just have to keep those
things in mind particularly when you're
evaluating your complicated icu patients
or your post
post-surgical patients and that's where
the dynamic can be very useful
particularly in your post-operative
patients if the level's declining that's
helpful if
it's you know rising that's concerning
but you kind of have to have the trend
there
there are some non-bacterial cytokine
activation syndromes that can cause
pro-calcium to go up
some forms of vasculitis and acute graft
versus host can cause this
malaria and fungal infections can cause
this and then chronic renal disease can
cause
mild increases in procalcitonin and the
way that i usually think about this
is chronic renal disease is a
pro-inflammatory state and if you
measure lots of different inflammatory
markers they're all mildly elevated
in chronic renal disease and then stage
renal disease
and so procalcitonin is one of those now
how high is it
well it tends to run in the 0.25 to 0.5
and maybe up to 1
range but the really lows are still
useful like if it's negative
you know it's it's still negative and
the really highs typically i think of
anything over one to two
is high uh that's still pretty useful
those sort of in-between values can be a
little difficult to interpret in these
patients and again
the trend can be more useful there and
then there are some dysregulated
syndromes where you give agents that
stimulate
cytokines like some of our organ
transplant induction agents
and il2 and granulocyte transfusions and
then a perineoplastic syndrome for like
metroid thyroid cancer small cell lung
cancer where you're producing calcitonin
is going to have a lot of procalciton
produced
so those are confounders really
important you understand those and think
about those and use those when
interpreting procalcitonin
now i am not going to show you any of
the diagnostic studies on procalcitonin
there have been a plethora
many 50 70 lots um and there's a reason
for that so the way that we evaluate
diagnostic markers i've sort of built
this diagram to show it is first we do
observational studies where we take 100
people with bacteremia and we measure a
level
of procalcitonin you know whatever
biomarker you want to measure
after we've done a bunch of those
studies we combine them into a
meta-analysis and we say this is how
good this is there's sensory specificity
positive negative predictive value
the problem with all of those studies is
they generally are observational
and they don't look at the impact of the
of the actual diagnostic test
they also use varying gold standards of
diagnosis
um and we've already talked about how
plural our diagnostic gold standard is
in pneumonia and sepsis
they use different cutoffs some of the
studies in pro calisthenics use
different assays
they're done in very different clinical
settings and there's a huge amount of
selection by so this is the main problem
i think with diagnostic studies
is they pick people we already know have
the diagnosis when we use diagnostic
tests
we pick people we think might have the
diagnosis
we don't know that if we knew they had
bacteria we wouldn't need the diagnostic
test
and so what's really useful and i think
relatively rare in the diagnostic
testing literature are due to randomized
trials where we take
a clinical problem and we randomize
people to utilization of a diagnostic
test
or they're not utilizing that diagnostic
test and the interesting thing is in pro
calcium we have a
bucket load of randomized controlled
trials so money that we can do
a bunch of meta-analyses and so you know
we're not going to talk about these
observational states there have been at
least
five or seven i can't even keep track of
the number of meta-analyses
looking at the density specificity
positive negative predictive value of
procalcitonin for diagnosing infection
but what really we need to know is where
the rubber meets the road
what happens when i use it to make
decisions that's what really matters and
that's where i think
we really in pro calcitonin have the
data and a lot of other diagnostic tests
we don't have the data i have down here
a citation for what i think is one of
the better
meta-analyses on this topic the
discussion is actually what i really
like here because they talk about how
pro calcium is not also it's also not a
dichromatous test it's not a positive
versus negative
it's a test where 0.2 means something
different than 2 which means something
different than 20.
and you can't take that into account in
the way that we statistically evaluate
tests like good ratios and the sensing
specificity it's very difficult
so where are we going to talk about well
the best data on procalcitonin is in
respiratory tract infections
and sepsis here are a list of other
areas where it's been studied
some have better evidence than others
what i would say
is that the best evidence isn't what i'm
going to talk about but you can find
data in all these other areas and so
let's talk about loris retract infection
first
so this is the first randomized trial
done 16 years ago
what they did was they took patients
presenting to the eb with lower straight
tract infections pneumonia acute
bronchitis
exacerbations of chronic bronchitis etc
they did a single blinded trial where in
one group they randomized them to pct
guided antibiotic use
in the other group they said you just do
your thing
they had a pct algorithm where if the
level was 0.5 or less they discouraged
0.25 or less they discouraged
antibiotics it was over 0.25 they
encouraged it and depending on how low
or high it was they might have
more strongly discouraged or increased
if antibiotics weren't started they
recommended repeating it at 6 to 24
hours and they allowed physician
overruling because we always want to
treat patients and not lab values
that's how we make decisions and every
study of procalcitonin is allowed
physician overruling
and in this study was about 18
what did they find well their clinical
outcome and and this is the key question
can we
decrease antibiotic use safely
without hurting a bunch of people and in
this study they did
they decreased antibiotic initiation and
a bunch of people didn't die because
they didn't get antibiotics which is
often the reason people start
antibiotics well they might get worse
they might die if i don't give
antibiotics they'll
have sepsis and so we give antibiotics
we don't think some of those people
probably need them
but that's what we do to be on the safe
side and so in this study there was no
difference in mortality no difference in
length of stay but antibiotic
prescriptions dropped by
nearly half and antibiotic days of
therapy dropped by about half
what you can see is in conditions where
antibiotics were rarely needed like
asthma bronchitis accused exacerbations
of bronchitis
um you know most of those people don't
need antibiotics but
maybe a couple do and that's where they
had the greatest benefit and that they
cut antibiotic use
a lot but even in community acquired
pneumonia they decreased it
significantly
so about 10 percent overall we know
there are viral pneumonias out there
and they don't benefit from antibiotics
when they have a virus
and so even in that group there was some
benefit
there have been a variety of other
trials i mean there's probably been 15
or 20 trials of norse retract infection
i'm going to show you the largest trials
so they multi-center non-inferiority
randomized trial for adults presenting
same thing lower subtract infection to
the ed they had six facilities
enrolled over 1300 patients what they
did here was not only do
pro-calcium levels that had admission
but also on day three
five and seven and they used a very
similar algorithm as you can see
less than 0.25 don't give antibiotics
more more than 0.25 give them
they had some things like hey if they're
super sick you should probably just
start antibiotics
they had some little nuances around copd
and severity of illness
and then they said if the pro calcitonin
on day 3 5 or 7
in less than 0.25 you should stop the
antibiotics
or if it's declined to about 80 to 90
percent of the peak
off the peak you should stop antibiotics
so if it was a 20 and now it's a 2
you can stop antibiotics what did they
find in this study
well compliance here was about 91
percent
overall antibiotic exposures were
reduced by 35 percent again it varied
least decrease was in community acquired
pneumonia is about 30 percent but in
copd it was 65
the overall antibiotic prescription rate
declined by 12
mean antibiotic exposures decreased
three days
and we gave less antibiotics and saw
less antibiotic adverse events
and we didn't see any increased other
adverse events like
readmission empiema recurrence of
infection and actually it
kind of favored the pro-calcitonin side
and there was no difference in mortality
which is always what you want to see
we're not
we're using less antibiotics but we're
not killing people
this is a meta-analysis and i think this
is the best
most recent meta-analysis and what this
is is it took all of the trials 26
trials
6 700 patients with lower surtract
infection they were
all randomized trials now they incurred
in occurred of varying settings
mostly hospital and ed that was about
85 percent cap half that bronchitis copd
exacerbation
but there were some clinic patients
included in that an upper estro tract
infection
and they did a patient level
meta-analysis which is a little
different than a regular meta-analysis
which just takes study outcomes and
combines them
the patient level analysis you take the
individual patient outcome
and you combine them into a single study
so it's a little more robust way of
doing it
and what you can see is they were able
to decrease antibiotic initiation
at each time point and overall
antibiotic use by about two and a half
days
now the really interesting finding in
the study was people who are in the
pro-calc toner group
actually had decreased mortality
compared to the usual care group
and so why was that well there was a
question
was there less actual treatment failure
in the procalcitonin group
length of stay didn't differ there
definitely were less antibiotic side
effects and so why do we see this
mortality difference well there's a
couple thoughts on this we don't
actually know the reason
one of the thoughts is less antibiotics
may be better for patients
less side effects less toxicity less c
diff
less renal dysfunction less multi drug
resistance and so that's that's probably
good for patients
another thought is procalcitonin helps
to
point us in the right direction in that
if you have a bacterial pneumonia
you want to give antibiotics and maybe
iv fluids if you have
heart failure which can look very
similar with tachycardia and tachypnea
and infiltrates and shortness of breath
and maybe a mildly elevated white count
that doesn't benefit from antibiotics
and it definitely doesn't benefit from
fluids it needs
diuretics and so there's a question of
boy you know
is procalcitonin telling us it's not
infection go look for other stuff and
helping us to treat
other stuff by their by not sort of
always saying hey we should just give
some antibiotics
and some diuretic it's actually a really
interesting study that i don't have in
here
where they looked at antibiotic use in
patients with heart failure and atrial
fibrillation what they found is
people with afib where they clearly had
afib still got lots of antibiotics
because people thought it was pneumonia
and you may not know this but
antibiotics contained a lot of sodium
and so those patients
needed longer in the hospital needed a
lot more diuretics
and there were actually some really
negative side effects of not treating
the condition correctly so
i think that may be a possibility
although i wouldn't say it's been
clearly
identified also there may be some
benefit to sort of customizing this some
people could get a lot shorter some
people could get longer
but i think it's left to be sort of
elucidated the mechanism for this
these are the algorithms we use at our
institution they're very similar to
those pro-hosp algorithms less than 0.25
don't give antibiotics greater than 0.25
do
we recommend repeating every two to
three days we don't do them daily and
large retract infection
certainly people are really sick you can
start antibiotics and just monitor
you don't start it's reasonable to
repeat in six to 12 hours if you're
concerned about bacterial infection
and then we use a similar algorithm for
follow-up or if it's less than 0.25 or
drop 80
we encourage discontinuation now if it's
rising or not adequately decreasing
that's where we sort of say hey let's
take a second look and make sure we're
not missing anything
and so just some conclusions from these
respiratory tract trials
tct based antimicrobial use decreases
antibiotic use without any adverse
clinical outcomes then there's a
suggestion it may improve outcome
its effect on antibiotic use really
varies based on underlying patient
population is it the icu versus
outpatient
and frankly the disease state cap versus
copd exacerbation
and i don't have time to show that data
but it is a little variable in its
impact
what about sepsis so sepsis is really a
dilemma these are my two venn diagrams
for sepsis both the old one
and the new one sepsis is not an
infection that's what i try to
tell our residents sepsis is not treated
with antibiotics the infection that's
causing sepsis is treated with
antibiotics
but in fact the only sepsis specific
therapy we actually use are fluids and
pressers and we actually don't have
anything to treat the underlying problem
of sepsis
it's a non-specific diagnosis right it's
organ dysfunction in the setting of i
think they might have an infection
cultures take time so we give lots of
antibiotics because
we don't want to miss because we know
people with sepsis have bad outcomes
and so we accept the negative of giving
lots of antibiotics to some people who
don't need them
because we think we're going to benefit
people in the long run
now all that use leads to toxicity super
infection resistance and so we need some
tools to help us make some decisions
this is the largest multi-center well
not the largest
one of the larger trials looking at
multi-center randomized trial of sepsis
treatment with procalcitonin very
similar to pneumonia
the one thing i'd point out is they used
a cut point of 0.25 a 0.5
why did they use a cutoff point of 0.5
to say give or don't give
one of the reasons is pro calcium has
been approved for diagnosis sepsis at a
level of 0.5 for many years
that seems to sort of be the better cut
point for the icu
excuse me and that's probably because
there's just more inflammatory sort of
milieu in the icu and so we're improving
the
specificity of the test while trying not
to degrade the sensitivity if that makes
sense you remember shifting your curve
so you can improve your
your test for your test performance
in this trial they had similar things
they took patients were admitted to the
ic with sepsis
who were going to get started on
antibiotics they did a pro calcitonin
they said it was greater than 0.5 start
if less than 0.5
don't start and then it has some similar
rule for stopping
they found overall antibiotic exposure
was decreased by about two and a half
days
there was no difference in mortality
adherence was way lower
like 50 um and so
seemed to have some benefit although
certainly not the same benefit that we
saw in loris retract infection
and so to follow that up there was
another randomized trial this is a
multi-set or randomized trial evaluating
not tcp initiation
but only pct discontinuation the reason
they did this
is it's really hard for the icu doctors
not to start broad spectrum not to start
some antibiotics
in their really sick patients um and i
understand it's really hard for me to
say
hey don't start antibiotics and somebody
who's gotten really sick they tend to
just start whether
you know no matter what things say and
so this trial looked at
discontinuation and it was done in
dutch icus and it's important to
understand that it was done in dutch
icu's why is that important
the dutch are very conservative in their
antibiotic utilization they use less
antibiotics and
you know many other countries in europe
they use less antibiotics than we do in
the us
they use less broad spectrum they use
shorter durations and so
one of the arguments against
prokalstonin was hey we're already using
way too many people just use
less antibiotics in general may not it
probably wouldn't have a benefit
and so again they took patient's icu or
admitted resumed infection
and they did procalcitonin for stopping
so they measured it when they came in
but they didn't say to stop
unless the pct dropped to less than 0.5
or to decrease from 80 percent from the
peak and then they said hey we think you
should stop antibiotics
what was the result of this trial well
they decreased antibiotic use
and then interestingly they actually
found decreased mortality these are the
actual outcomes you can see whether it's
defined on daily doses or duration of
therapy it was significantly decreased
in the pro calcium group from standard
care of seven which is a pretty a
conservative standard for icu duration
of therapy for sepsis
um pretty right on with the guidelines
uh to five days which is shorter than
the guideline
length of stay was no different but
interestingly again mortality was
different
so i think the same the same things
i think with mortality but particularly
here continued exposure to broad
spectrum antibiotics and numerous other
studies
not looking at pro-calcium have been
associated with
bad outcomes in the icu
so this is a meta-analysis of
pro-calcium gut antibiotic therapy and
critically ill adults
i would say it's a little bit more
homogeneous
um with the i squared being zero but
generally decreased antibiotics
uh antibiotic use it was weaker
strengths
didn't change length of stay and
interestingly in this meta-analysis
coherence didn't really influence
outcomes and so i think um my opinion
is just my opinion these are our
guidance and so we use the same
algorithm
0.5 less than 0.5 we have this big red
box that says hey if your patient's
really sick and you think they have an
infection probably reasonable just start
and then monitor every day or two and
when it drops to less than 0.5
or greater than 80 of the peak you
should stop and so that's sort of been
our strategy i think
for sepsis uh really very useful i think
for
getting people off of antibiotics a lot
earlier even at 48 hours because that's
often what happens is they get started
on antibiotics because nobody knows
exactly why they've crashed and burned
the probe calcium says low you have good
evidence that stopping antibiotics in
those patients is safe
unless you've found some specific
infection and so at 48 hours 72 hours
that should
really be pushed on instead of saying
let's give them five to seven days
because they got better on
antibiotics and so there are some issues
with the sepsa studies they do have a
lot of overruling i will mention in that
dutch study
it was 90 compliance at 24 hours after
the recommendation
there are selective populations with
different uh different problems
the renal dysfunction issue does come in
here with acute kidney injury and some
of those
mid-range values but my take on this is
pro-calcium-based treatment appears safe
particularly when we're using it for
antibiotic discontinuation
and patients with pcp values that have
normalized or decreased significantly
should really think about stopping
antibiotics now
when is pro calcium not useful well we
talked about localized infection that's
one place
i want to talk about the proact trial
which is a large u.s
which is unique in that most of those
other trials are done in europe u.s
randomized trial of pct use and loris
retract infections then at 14 hospitals
not
previously utilized it they introduced
it using sort of a qi
process and they randomized to
pct-guided or usual care
they enrolled over 1600 patients over a
couple of years
they had about half of those patients
hospitalized about a third were copd a
quarter of acute bronchitis and only
about 20 percent were capped
now what they found in this study
was that pro-calcium didn't decrease
antibiotic use at all
uh in any way that you measured it now
what i would point out
is that the usual care antibiotic
duration of therapy
was four days which is really low
um and much lower than any of the
previous trials that had ever been
published using procalcitonin their
control groups had been much higher
91 of patients had a pro-calcium value
less than 0.25 suggesting
most of them didn't need antibiotics to
start out with they also enrolled a lot
more of the non-severely ill
and low prevalence of community acquired
pneumonia compared to a number of the
other trials i
showed you and so my conclusion from
this
was not the pro calcium doesn't work but
that
in a patient population where i'm
already going to use a really short
course of antibiotics
it probably isn't going to shorten it up
much if i'm going to give only three to
five days of antibiotics
it may not be useful and the new
community acquired pneumonia guidelines
recommend against the use of
procalcitonin
to decide duration of therapy they say
give everybody five days
which you know if you give everybody
five days
make some sense but at our institution i
wouldn't say
five days would be kind of unusual for a
cap therapy so if you really are going
to use short courses of antibiotics
i agree pro calcium may not decrease
antibiotic utilization
if you already think it's really
unlikely this person has a bacterial
infection
or i'm 100 confident they have bacterial
infection
it may not be useful in helping you to
diagnose them
but most of us operate in areas of some
uncertainty
and so i think it still has some utility
all right i want to mention a couple
things on pct and covent and so i put
this disclaimer here
because with all things coveted we could
rapidly revise everything we've said
when new better literature comes out
but what i would say from my review of
the literature as of a couple weeks ago
was that pct values in covet are
generally low
the median pcp value in 5900 cases in
new york city was .2
and range down from 0.1 to 0.6 now the
crp
in contrast was pretty high and so crp
seems to be
something that goes up a lot higher in
covid
than the procalcitonin now pro-calcium
values do vary based on severity of
illness
and the sicker you are the higher your
pro-calcium values are
and internally that value may actually
be predictive
and i'll show you that here in a minute
but this is just some data from
uh hospitalized patients with covid
it was a much larger population but you
know a big chunk of it they didn't have
final outcomes on and since what they
had
what you can see is those who survive
generally had
lower procalcitonin values those who
died generally came in with at least
some mild elevation
these are pct values in moderate to
critical cobit 19.
what you can see is those with
non-severe disease generally have very
relatively low pro calcium values almost
always less than 0.5
those with severe critically ill
patients have higher values but again
not that high those who were discharged
generally had
decreases in their procalcitonin while
those who
died had their procalcitonin rising
and so elevated pro-calcitonins do seem
to predict for bad
outcomes there already have been and i
was amazed at the number of
meta-analyses
already available on different
biomarkers in uh covid
um 45 studies with 4 200 patients
and elevated whatever that means
procalcitonin in this study predicted
icu admission
but not odds or mortality where in this
study
amid a different meta-analysis it was
associated with a
combined poor outcome of mortality
severe disease in icu and particularly
a procal greater than 0.5 and it looked
like it may have actually been better
than crp or some of the other biomarkers
but
you know who knows on this one which
biomarker is the best
my own opinion is you should pick one
biomarker and go with it
but it seems to be a marker if it's
elevated for
a worse outcome now is that because
those patients also have bacterial
co-infection or it's something
with covid i'm i don't know the answer
to that
uh this is just a nice study that looked
at empiric antibacterial therapy
in um and uh co-infection in covid
because that's sort of the concern these
patients all present from the community
they have infiltrates and fevers they
might have bacterial infection or they
might have cohen
this was a random sample of 1700
patients who had coveted in
michigan they looked at early antibiotic
use only and bacterial co-infection
over half of patients got antibiotics
and they defined a bacterial
co-infection in three percent uh and so
bacterial co-infection at the time of
presentation is relatively uncommon
in fact i'd call it very uncommon the
predictors of bacterial infection were
being older
from a long-term care facility
malnourished having kidney disease or
being really sick or having leukocytosis
they measured procals in about half the
population a level of 0.5 was actually
the strongest predictor for bacterial
infection
but about 20 of those with over 0.5
didn't have a bacterial infection
defined is that because they couldn't
define it and they had one or because
they really didn't it was just bad covid
we don't know
pct of less than 0.1 had a negative
predictive value of
almost 99 for bacterial infection so
again i think
the level is useful if it's really low
probably not
a bacterial infection if it's over 0.5
it
probably is if it's in between it's a
little hard to know what to say because
could it be bad covid
could it be bacterial i think there
you're sort of watching the trend
and trying to make some decisions based
on your testing results
so it's a little tricky uh as the
literature emerged
to know how to interpret it a couple
last comments on implementation and then
i'll go through a couple cases so if you
have procalcitonin
or thinking of implementing it i think
it really helps to have a local expert
somebody that people can ask questions
of
somebody can say hey i got this what do
you think what do you think is going on
whether it's in the lab
pathologist whether that's an id
physician whether that's a stewardship
pharmacist
somebody it's good to develop
recommendations of what to do
and how to use it and how to interpret
it not just put a value out there
that turns red when it's some number but
it's good to like tell people what you
think they should do
because this lab does require a little
bit of interpretation
it's i think good to encourage people to
use it where it has utility
because through track infection sepsis
and don't use it where it doesn't
cystitis localized abscess uti
there's a little literature out there
but i would say it's not ready for prime
time in this area
uh i would look at processes to avoid
inappropriate unnecessary use so we
don't allow people to order daily
procalcitones
um because you know we looked and some
patients had 30 procalcitonins over 30
days which means
no one's doing anything with that data
and so that's just a waste of blood and
a waste of money
and so you want to have some sort of
process to help make sure it's used
appropriately
i think it's useful when you're
presenting the data to not just put it
in your lab
report but to put it where people look
at infection related data we have a
screen where we have fever and white
count and procalcitonin and antibiotics
and culture results
and it's all sort of a one stop shop for
all your infection related data so i
think it's useful to put it there
and then i think having a stewardship
team involved can help with this
in one study where there's a local
stewardship team plus a pcp algorithm
they were able to decrease antibiotic
use by about 20 percent
and then in another study where they
looked at community hospitals where they
had pct available
and compared to community hospitals
where they didn't they saw
decreased length of stay and a
non-significant decrease in the body use
was 1.5 days
and they shortened had a shorter length
of stain now is that all from
procalcitonin
hard to tell those places with pcb also
had pharmacist-driven algorithms
so there is suggestion that you know
combining these with stewardship
really is probably the uh the best way
to do this as it is with like bra
all the rapid diagnostics for infection
so key points the dynamics are very
important and very useful
you want to keep in mind the confounders
when interpreting you want to use them
in syndromes where they have data
loris retract infection sepsis don't use
them where they don't have data
don't use them if you're not going to
use it right why get a lab you're going
to ignore
and so don't bother getting it if you're
not going to do anything with it
if you and that's what i always tell my
residents if the test will not
change your treatment today why are we
doing it
um and then usually we don't recommend
testing more than every two to three
days unless you're in an ambiguous
situation we're like well
i want to do one it's low i don't think
needing antibiotics but i'm kind of
nervous
i'll do one in six to 12 hours and if
that's negative i'll feel really
comfortable that we're not giving
anybody
so with that i will stop and go through
a couple of cases all these cases are
people that i've seen
so 65 year old female recently
discharged from the hospital
had a acute mi got a stead she comes in
with shortness of breath over the last
day
she's a cough productive of a little bit
of sputum
hypoxic in her facility no beaver chills
she does have leukocytosis
mild elevation lactic acid mild acute
kidney injury chest x-ray shows interval
left
right left greater than right new
opacities especially the bases
is it edema is it an infection uh so the
question is really is this sepsis
without a lactic acid
an acute kidney injury which needs
antibiotics and you know 30 ml per kilo
or is this heart failure with some renal
hypoperfusion
lord pro cal was .0 less than 0.05
and so the ed gave her a dose of
antibiotics but the medicine team did
not
and her ef was like 30 percent and she
had nuance at a-fib
and they gave her a bunch of diuretics
and by the next day she was way better
so zelsan and 30 mls per kilo would not
be the way to treat this patient and the
pro calcium is useful
for helping us sort that out 77 year old
female
with dementia o2 dependency opd presents
from long-term care for this altered
mental status increased o2 need
coverage been in the facility she's got
crackles on exams she's febrile or white
counts eight
she's got biohazy opacities maybe
developing consolidations or pct's 0.13
so this is a little iffy to me this
sounds a lot like coven
i wouldn't generally start antibiotics
but if i didn't i'd repeat a procal in 6
to 12 hours
if you said well i'll start tonight and
repeat tomorrow morning and if it's
still low
we'll see what my cova test is and as
long as pct's low and covets positive
we'll stop the antibiotics that would
also be a reasonable strategy that's
actually what she had she had
and then last case i always like to
throw in cases where
it wasn't useful just to show you how
you have to kind of think through these
things so it's a 29 year female who has
transferred our facility
she had a rash she had fever joint pains
renal failure headache
confusion she had a macular rash
multiple areas of synovitis
she didn't have neck stiffness or other
exam findings her white count was
elevated her creatinine was elevated she
had blood and white cells in her urine
her inflammatory markers were high her
compliments were low no procal was six
and a half
and so it looked like lupus but if you
read the literature on lupus prokalstone
generally isn't supposed to be elevated
in lupus at least that's what i was able
to find
um and so she got covered with vanco and
subtraction because of her fever
and headache and um we did a big workup
didn't find anything the rheumatologist
initially said it's not lupus
but then when the anaes came back
they're like well yeah i i guess it is
lupus
and she had lupus with cerebritis and so
her proton on day four was actually
like four still but because she was much
better
we had an alternative diagnosis we said
well we'll stop the antibiotics and just
watch and she did fine off of
antibiotics and so
that's where you really do have to put
the lab values in context of the patient
that you really need those antibiotics
start out with probably not but i think
even without pro calc you probably
really got treated with them until we
ruled infection now
so that i will stop and take
questions
thank you dr van for your presentation
we'll now go ahead and start the live q
a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
all right your first question is
as an antimicrobial stewardship
pharmacist
how can i motivate physicians to
actually integrate
pro calcite and ordering and
interpretation
to their practice at my hospital yeah
good good question
so how do you get people to use it
because this is really the tool of the
hospitalist
less than the id doctor because the
patients we see are very complicated
and difficult sometimes to interpret and
so i think the way to do this is to
build this into standardized protocols
whether that's you build it into your
community acquired pneumonia
whether you build that into your
exacerbations of copd order set
your sepsis order sets and then i think
it helps to
have a champion for that and then
utilize that to utilize that person or
those persons
to uh to move this forward so for our
facility we use our pharmacist a lot
and so we developed basically some
guidance on exacerbations of copd
we did a bunch of education for our
clinicians we put this
you know pro customer order set
developed an order set and then
um our team based pharmacists actually
look at procalcitonin and say hey the
pro costs are really low
can we stop the antibiotics and so i
think one thing you have to do is
educate people but you also have to sort
of remind them because
education doesn't always doesn't stick
and so it helps to build it in
that this is how we manage things and
these are our guidance so you have to
make people aware
build it into their practice and then
remind them that that's their practice
eventually they kind of learn that
that's how we do things
great thank you okay your next question
is there any data that supports the role
of pct biomarker use
in changing antimicrobial agent and or
dose
yeah i don't know for dose uh you know
where you would use it to change
antimicrobial agent would be perhaps
that non-declining procalcitona now
i would not tell you to routinely change
there was actually study a randomized
trial where they randomized people
to who had non-declining or rising
procalcitones to either
usual care or escalation of antibiotics
and additional imaging
they found there was no benefit and
there was actually harm
to routinely escalating antibiotics and
doing imaging
which to me is not surprising because
again we're you know
treating lab values not patients and
we're doing things that don't
necessarily need to be done
like giving contrast eye and broad
spectrum antibiotics
and so you really have to make that as
an individualized patient decision
in the context of the clinical scenario
and so that rising or
you know non-declining might be a place
where i think about it but i'd want to
make sort of an intelligent decision
based on my re-evaluation of the patient
and i wouldn't really look for a
non-declining in the first 24 to sort of
36 48 hours
because it'll sort of peak out there at
12 to 24 at 12 hours-ish
um and so you may not catch quite that
peak and so it's really at that 36
you know that's 72 96 hours that you're
like we should start to see some
improvement at this point
okay your next question during the
recent sepsis alliance two-day summit
no there was no mentioning of pct by any
of the presentations that i watched
why is there still so much resistance to
use of the biomarker
despite all of the many publications
showing
its benefit both in sepsis and lower
respiratory tract infection
yeah good question um so there are
uh yeah that's a great question i think
part of the problem is uh for id doctors
they have found it not super useful and
that's
because of the bias of id patients and
that nobody calls us about simple easy
to sort out patients and like i
mentioned this is really the
more the hospitalist or the intensivist
tool
um the studies have generally been done
in europe now why europe would be so
much different than the us i don't know
um i think there's also people look at
the newly journal study
and say oh it didn't work in the u.s but
don't understand the differences between
that population
and all the other population studies and
so i think there's a combination
of um you know
bias against maybe some of the european
literature
you know some id doctors who are strong
voices who are non-believers
but you know my opinion is we need tools
to help us make better decisions with
antibiotics
is it a perfect tool no it's not perfect
but you know
what else do we have show me a better
marker with better
data um because there just isn't one
right now
um so you know i don't know why people
people talk about
icu stewardship i mean if we treated
everybody with five days of antibiotics
in icu
maybe we don't need pro calcium but that
is not my experience in my icu
okay thank you now this next question
has pcp utilization increased since
kovid
now directly related to covid or
possibly other factors
oh it's hard to know if it's increased i
would say it's routinely measured on
admission
i would say our clinicians use it in
helping sort of in making their overall
decision about whether we need to
give antibiotics or can withhold
i don't know that it's increased it's
really hard to say
mostly because patient our patient-like
census has fluctuated so much with cobit
and that we had a lot of covet and then
we didn't have very much
and it's kind of gone up and down i
would say it's routinely used
in our covet patient um but i would say
it's it's pretty routinely used at our
institution in general
okay now other than the confounders you
mentioned causing pct to elevate are
there any others
those are the ones that i'm aware of
there may be other confounders
um it's i didn't put together an
exhaustive list
i don't know of exhaustive lists but
that's a list i've sort of accumulated
over time
okay great thank you now um next
question
how is pct cleared does renal impairment
have an effect on decreasing levels
yeah it can have some effect uh it is
cleared somewhat
renally maybe some through dialysis and
that's where it can be a little
difficult to interpret in some of those
icu patients
um and so but again really low
useful high useful it's that sort of .25
to one ish
one and a half can be a little hard to
interpret
but generally i've interpreted it you
know as i normally would
keeping those sort of nuances in there
and nobody really knows the answers to
how much or when or
that just as far as i know isn't
available there's a nice review of the
literature that's been published in
clinical infectious disease
a couple years ago addressing this topic
sort of summarizing
how to interpret pro-calcium into the
setting of renal dysfunction
okay great thank you now among the
physicians utilizing
pct today in the us what percentage
would you say are familiar with the
cutoff values and recommended actions
for each of the cutoffs oh that that and
that's the difficult part right
it depends by center how how well people
understand it
and that's where it's it's actually even
difficult when you bring it on in your
lab in the jabbed up discussion
which value am i am i going to flag is
abnormal am i going to flag the 0.25 or
am i going to flag the 0.5
is it used for sepsis does it use for
larger tract infection because
you know the lab doesn't know which is
being used for so we flag it at anything
over 0.1
because point one is sort of where you
might think about it maybe in your bad
cp exacerbations
um but it you know it's highly variable
and my
my sense is that nuance is sometimes
lost on people
okay thank you dr van you have time for
just a few more questions here
now you have very very nicely stated
that pct is a tool
for the hospitalist now what about the
em practitioner
emergency medicine that's so what i
would say is that's where
most of the studies were actually done
were done starting in the ed where they
did pct and the ed
and decided whether they should start
antibiotics we have not utilized it
quite that much that way just because
our ed doctors if it takes more than
five minutes tend to uh
think it takes too long and so they want
a result very rapidly but i think
it has great utility in the eb and
that's actually all those lowest retract
infections except for like the hap and
the vaps and things like that
were done in patients presenting to the
eb with larger tract infection
great thank you okay let's go ahead and
wrap up with this last question
and how do you have pct ordered in your
hospital
is that independent of other tests or
attached with antibiotic order
etc good question so we have it
generally independent now it's built
into our order sets for pneumonia and
copd exacerbation and sepsis
it's part of some of our automatic
sepsis protocols that it gets measured
um but just because of how people order
it we tend to build it into order sets
or these protocols for those things
not you can't really so it is with the
antibiotics in the sense that it's with
the order set with the antibiotics that
along with everything else but i think
it's important that you put it with
those things right if you have a sepsis
protocol
having pro calcium be a part of that
would be a reasonable decision
because it has some utility there if
your site decides that something it
wants to do
thank you again dr van do you have any
final comments for our audience before
we close today
uh i don't believe that i do i'd
encourage if you're interested to read
some of the
studies that i cited uh in my slides
here
great thank you again for your time
today and for your important research
and we would also like to thank lavers
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions as a
reminder
any questions we did not have time for
today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labberts will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
again thank you dr van and until next
time
take care bye thank you